hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of my freeto playay flipping
Series where we're going to go from 50
to 100 Mil using freeo play items only
uh last episode we ended at about 60 mil
uh so we're going to see where we can go
from here pretty excited a couple new
items I realized are free to play just
the other day that is a ring of coins
and the Ring of nature are actually
freeto play items uh so we're going to
give those a try at some point today and
yeah let's get into it all right so to
start off we might uh do some gilded
chain bodies they have worked pretty
well in the past uh looks like they have
about a 50 60k margin on it right now uh
so we'll go for 10 of those next up is
this wooden Shield G uh it's kind of an
interesting item uh looks like a 40K
margin on it though and I've literally
never seen this item before but
apparently it is in existence uh so
we're going to buy it for about 200 and
hopefully sell it for 240 uh which be a
pretty decent profit so we maybe go for
10 of those as well and uh the Gilded
Scimitar is a pretty expensive item but
but it does have a 150 hey margin on it
or something like that I could buy it
for about 8 mil and sell it for about
8150 uh which it's pretty good I mean
cost wise it might not be the best but
yeah I don't know still reasonable uh so
we could probably afford maybe two of
these because we do want to do another
item at least uh 88 or
8020 and uh and we'll go for two
maybe uh
nah we'll go for most of our money here
let's see if we can go for six I
actually haven't really figured out a
better item yet all right and uh six
there we go we just had to reduce one of
our other items quickly but yeah we'll
come back with hopefully some
sales
[Music]
uh now the Gilded armor set is something
I've been meaning to do more often there
just big spike in the middle here that
kind of messes up the graph uh we we'll
try buying them for
4320 and uh maybe we can actually get
100K margin on that gilded armor set
LG and uh 40 through2 able just use the
rest of our money so we might be able to
get five we'll go for seven looks like
we can afford all right guys uh we'll
come back in a day or two when these
items have sold all right and we're back
and most of our flips went quite well uh
the chain bodies we got 54k on each one
and four of those Nets us about
216k uh the iron gold sets 50k in each
one nine of those gives us
440k uh the team gape X's came in huge
with with 120k profit on each one uh
giving us
171k just over a mil and the guilted
sets gave us about 100K on each seven of
those gives us well 700k in total that's
about 2.4 milon profit uh which I'm
extremely happy with let's go see if we
can re uh replicate that
again okay so to start off I think we're
going to do uh the monk robe uh bottoms
have about a 100K on them which is
pretty good and we'll maybe go for five
these hopefully 1681 and 5 sounds good
uh next up a interesting item is the
zamak plate body uh has about 200 250
traded a day currently has a 10K margin
on it which is extremely good uh so
we'll try this out for 55 600 uh not 55
mil that would be a little insane 55600
and we'll just go for 70 see if we can
figure out a b limit or so and um yeah
that looks good uh next up I think we're
going to do the iron gold armor set set
again worked pretty well last time uh
we'll try buying them for just over a
mil and uh it's not actually at that
price right now but we're going to see
if we can snipe it for later hopefully
it'll drop down and oh now we'll go for
the one5 cuz it's a little more
reasonable and we'll go for 10 of those
and last up we'll probably go for the
monk robe top uh just seems to work
pretty well and at this point in the
recording we hadn't figured out that the
nature ring was actually free to play as
well as a ring of coins which I am
definitely going to try in this episode
uh but I hadn't quite realized that yet
thanks to the wiki I now know that ring
of coins ring of nature are the most
expensive items in free to play
currently um followed by the guilded
SARS and probably this item honestly uh
so we'll go and do six of these and
it'll come back when some stuff is sold
all right we're back and uh it was a
little Messier this time we definitely
didn't get uh the slam dunk profits we
did last time uh but we still did decent
the iron gold armor we only got 23k on
each one and 230k in total for the 10 of
them uh in the monks robe tops um sold
them in two different chunks uh we
bought them for about 40 uh
476k and sold them for
4766 K it's about 300K in profit so not
awful uh probably not worth the
investment though uh so we're going to
start off by uh changing the price on
these zamak plate bodies they've been in
there a long time uh we did sell about
10 of them for a 10K profit so that's
about 100K there uh maybe a bit less
than that but uh now we're going to drop
him down to 58k and hopefully they'll
sell then now one thing I mentioned
earlier is that on this wiki page it
states that the Ring of coins and the
Ring of nature became available at free
to play so I'm pretty excited to try
these out now the Ring of coins doesn't
seem to have a very good margin on it
but the Ring of nature U possibly
because it's traded a lot less
frequently uh has a big swing in the
price it goes from like 9800 to 10200 so
about 400k swing uh which would be
really awesome see ring and nature
totally available to free play never
knew that before I'm not sure when they
did this but hopefully we can get 2 or
300K profit on this item and 9825 and
we're going to go for three of them and
next up we're going to do the Gilded
citar we're going to keep uh just
expensive items today uh I don't know
why but the guilded syatar has been
traded quite a bit less the last half a
day or even a day so the price has
fluctuated and it's very high right now
but there is a chance of getting some
very good margins so we're going to try
for 884 5 now this is kind of risky uh
but I don't know we're going to go for a
highrisk reward play here uh cuz
normally this item is only about 8 mil
all right looks like we have a little
bit of money left so we're going to go
for the team Cape x uh sorry I lied team
Cape I and uh for about
1571 looks like we could get maybe a 80k
profit on each one which would be pretty
nice uh we can afford 10 of these all
right we'll come back when these items
have sold okay so the rings of nature
worked pretty well uh we got about a a
165k profit on each one and they they
did buy and sell a lot quicker than I
thought uh so in total we got 500k in
profit from those uh the guilded citar
we ended up actually losing money on but
just goes to show like I haven't lost
money on an item in a long time uh so
it's pretty safe flipping but that being
said we did lose about 96k on the Gilded
simitar and uh two of those about 200k
loss not the end of the world but still
not that great uh so next up I think
we're going to do the hill giant Club
looks to have a decent margin right now
uh going to buy them for
1261 and hopefully or maybe a little
more than 1261 I don't know hopefully
sell them for uh I think a 50k profit
almost we're going to go for eight of
them for no particular reason next up is
the Gilded plate legs now this isn't an
item I've actually tried before and as
with a couple other of the Gilded items
the price seems to be fluctuating a lot
more recently uh it seems to be less
coming in the game I've noticed uh these
high price fluctuations come with lower
volume in Supply uh so I'm not sure why
less guilded items are coming into the
game right now I'm not sure if there's a
change or just bad luck uh but anyway it
is a kind of decent opportunity to try
to get some higher margin flips mind you
that didn't work for the Gilded Scimitar
but I think we're going to give it
another try uh so we'll try for
2706 and we'll go for five sounds good
and uh the Ring of nature still has
about 170k profit on it
uh which is really good we might just
try investing like our entire cash stack
next into it uh but for now we're just
going to use our 34 mil which can afford
I guess we can afford three with that so
we're going to buy them for about
995k or something like that or
9913 and yeah we'll go for three and
yeah we'll come back hopefully with some
decent profit all right so uh these
flips didn't go so well uh so I think
that's probably going to end it for
today we'll start with the bad uh the
Gilded plate legs lost is 100k on each
one and that's about 400k in total uh
next is the cape eyes uh we actually
just broke even on uh so not terrible
not that great uh the hill giant club's
pretty decent we got a 41k margin on it
and uh seven of those gives us
287k in the ring of natures uh know it
looks like we have three but we
accidentally sold one to ourself uh so
only really two were profitable and it
gave us about 340k in total uh so not
awful we still made bit money on these
flips but a combination of uh some
lowering margins and my own stupidity uh
only gave us about 100K in total so
after all of said and done we're ending
the episode about 64.6 mil uh so we got
about uh 4.5 mil in profit this episode
it's getting pretty snowy outside so I
think uh unless I'm going to eat like
dry spaghetti for the next 3 days I
should go and buy some groceries before
I get snowed in and on that note I'm
going to say goodbye hope you guys
enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next episode
[Music]